thecus bio il faut être honnête on ne
voit plus beaucoup de monde dans les
cabines téléphoniques à l'ancienne la
quasi-totalité des particuliers ont des
portables alors france télécom a inventé
la cabine du futur avec un écran tactile
et des services en ligne gratuits
rassurez vous on peut tout de même il
téléphoné frédéric monteil emmanuel bec
à croire qu'ils s'étaient tous
téléphoner jamais une cabine
téléphonique n'avait attiré autant de
monde il faut dire qu'on nous présente
un modèle futuriste
tout simplement avec toutefois avec la
montage comme celle de la téléphonie
le bonheur n'est plus simple comme un
coup de fil pour séduire il faut un
écran tactile 10 minutes d'internet
gratuite et la possibilité de trouver le
restaurant ou la pharmacie la plus
proche de vous
aujourd'hui les usagers des cabines
actuelles sont à 94 ans sont des gens
qui ont un portable c'est un usage est
en réalité complémentaire de celui du
portable parce qu'il se peut qu'on
invente à décharger plus de batterie
c'est dans ces cas là aussi qu'on
utilise une cabine 12 prototype comme
celui ci sont installer et tester à
paris pendant six mois pour les étendre
au reste de la france il faudra
convaincre les usagers et c'est loin
d'être gagné
vous utilisez
le téléphone portable leur a été fatale
à paris elles ne sont utilisés que 50
petites minutes par jour pourtant elles
ont traversé les modes elles ont connu
les jetons les cadres ont servi de
refuge en cas de pluie de hunt bol de
décor de cinéma après 130 ans
d'existence même si c'est un peu
téléphoné
on peut dire qu'elle lance un nouvel
appel aux abonnés
et comme ça